رجل عمل صيني يقبع وراء القضبان في
الولايات المتحده بتهمه اختلاس مليار
دولار ليست هذه تهمه الفساد الاولى التي
يواجهها وانجوي فقد استقر في امريكا منذ
عشر سنوات بعد ان وجهت له توهم فساد في
الصين التي تلاحقه كما تلاحق غيره ممن
تصفهم بالفاسدين لدى بكين برنامج تديره
هيئه محاربه الفساد تحت اسم فوكس هاند اي
صيد الثعالب عدد من الدول الغربيه قليقه
من هذا الامر حيث تشك بان الصين تتخذ من
ملاحقه الفاسدين ذريعه لاجراء عمليه
استخباراتيه عبر ارسال عملائها للعمل في
سفاراتها في امريكا وغيرها من الدول تحت
غطاء انهم ملحقون دبلوماسيون قانونيون
لكن الروايه الرسميه الصينيه تقول ان
الهدف هو القبض على الفاسدين الهاربين
واعاده ما نهبوه من اموال في اطار التعاون
الدولي وتقول بكين انها نجحت من خلال
برنامج
ان تلقي القبض على عشره الاف وسبع مئه
متهم بالفساد وان تسترد ما يفوق خمسه
مليارات دولار
المحكمه الاوروبيه لحقوق الانسان اوقفت في
2022 ترحيل رجل تايواني تتهمه الصين
بالفساد في مجال الاتصالات مخافه ان يتعرض
للتعذيب الامر الذي يطرح تساؤلات عده حول
امكانيه استخدام بكين لبرامجها التي تقول
انها لمحاربه الفساد للقبض على المعارضين
لها في الخارج
انس نماسي العربيه